ماذا بقي من بخموت ومن بقي فيها سته اشهر
والمدينه تدك قصفا واستهدافا واضحت محطه
رهان الروس والاوكرانيين فهي رمز للصمود
الجيش كما سبق ان قال الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي وهي للروس الانتصار الرمزي
الاكبر بعد ان جفت خزائنهم من تحقيق
اختراق بارز على الجبهات يتحدث قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه عن استخدام
ميليشيات فاجنر وحداتها الاكثر استعدادا
لاختراق الدفاعات الاوكرانيه ومحاصره
المدينه
التصعيد في الايام الاخيره جعل المحور
الشمالي من بخموت اخطر المحاور واكثر
الجبهات سخونه رغم ان الهجوم على بخموت
يتم من الشمال والشرق وحتى الجنوب مراسل
الجزيره افاد بتمكن القوات الروسيه من
احداث ما يشبه اللسان بتقدمها بين قريتين
الاولى هي برفوفكا وتبعد نحو سته
كيلومترات ونصف عن وسط بخموت والقريه
الثانيه هي قريه يهدني وتبعد نحو
عن وسط مدينه بخموت وهذا الامر منح القوه
الروسيه فرصه لتكون اقرب الى الطريق
الوحيد المستخدم في هذه المناطق وهو
الطريق الالتفافي وبينما تتحدث القوه
الاوكرانيه عن استمرار سيطرتها في هذه
المناطق وعلى طرقها تدور معارك اخرى وان
بشكل اقل خطوره في المنطقه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه لبخموت تقول روسيا ان جميع
الطرق من والى بخموت اصبحت تحت السيطره
الناريه لقوتها فعلى ماذا تبحث موسكو
السيطره على بخموت تعد اطول المعارك التي
خاضتها روسيا خلال حربها على اوكرانيا حيث
تحاول منذ اكثر من سته اشهر احدى اختراق
فيها وتحقيق ذلك سيعني تمزيق خطوط الامداد
الاوكرانيه في الشرق ولكن العين بالاساس
على سلوفيانس واكراماتورسك لمنح فرصه
لتقدم قواتها والوصول الى اهم معاقل القوه
الاوكرانيه فيسك وهذا الاختراق سيعني ان
القوات الروسيه ستطبق بشكل شبه كامل على
منطقه دونيتسك بعد ان ظلت ممسكه بزمام
المبادره والسيطره في لوغاسك مما يجعل
اقليم دومباس بشكل كامل تحت سيطرتها يتهم
الاوكرانيون ميليشيات باستخدام ما يسمونه
تكتيك التدمير الكامل والارهاب بينما
يتحدث مؤسس فاغنر عن معلومات استخباراتيه
تؤكد بدء وصول الطلائع الاولى لدبابات الى
القوات الاوكرانيه قد يكون ذلك مؤشرا على
ان الحسم لن يكون سهلا للروس او بلا ثمن
في ظل دعم غربي للكياف تضخموت جزء من سوره
المشهد اجمالا فضل استعدادات لربيع ساخن